[Music]
greetings apiece welcome to the Dean
show another exciting show if you
haven't subscribed subscribe right now
how would you like to meet if you would
were able to if you had the opportunity
one of the founding fathers his one of
the children great-grandfather's let's
say you had a friend whose
great-grandfather was one of the
original signers of the Declaration of
Independence of this country for example
but my next guess
his grandfather was one of the original
signers of the Declaration of
Independence for the State of Israel and
his father was a general for the Israeli
army and we're gonna be talking about
his book the general son here on the D
show we've heard a lot of myths of Santa
Claus the to Bunny but these are some
great myths that he's going to be
dispelling here on the d show with my
next guest miko pilet don't go anywhere
[Music]
this is the how are you my collegue
alaikum Salam Greetings a piece thank
you for being with us here on the Deen
show peace activist you're the author of
the general Sun yeah and I made it you
know many people they would love to meet
one of the founding fathers someone
who's connected to them but your
grandfather was the founding one of the
founding fathers of the State of Israel
yeah well us about this was the
generation of my grandparents was the
generation of the first Jews to take on
Zionism as an ideology and take on this
idea of establishing a Jewish homeland
in Palestine and he was very active he
became a leader within the movement he
was a member of the de facto Jewish
government before the State of Israel
was established and he was one of the
signers on the declaration of
independence when the State of Israel
was established so that would be that
you can make a contrast like let's say
he was like the Abraham Lincoln or the
no I'm sorry I'm sorry George Washington
I'm sorry like a George Washington yes
okay and then from there your father
actually he was the general my father
was yes my father was both my parents
were born into Palestine so they were
the first generation Israelis if you
will first generation Jews were born
there and my father as a young man while
still in high school joined the Zionist
militia
give an officer so in the night the war
of 1948 when the Zionists occupied most
of Palestine he was an office already
and then he remained in the military as
a career officer and by 1967 he was
already a general and a member of the
Israeli Central Command the High Command
now something happened in your life some
very sad and tragic that your niece she
was killed by a suicide bomber is that
right
that's right now you didn't go off and
start to just blindly hate everybody
because I mean we know that this is
something despicable this is something
that is horrific and many people they
would just end up you know hating a
whole community a whole race because of
this and we see this you know happening
but you did something different well to
begin with the people who killed my
niece killed themselves as well so
there's nobody to hate even if I was
inclined to hate the inspiration to do
what I did actually came from my sister
my niece's mother because after this
happened and after the funeral the usual
questions that come up have to do with a
revenge and retaliation and and catching
who's responsible and so forth and then
hating a community this is what's what's
somehow expected for some reason well my
sister came out when she came out and
started talking to people and answering
questions because there's a lot of press
there was big news in Israel in fact
there was big news everywhere a lot in
all over the world because she was a
granddaughter of a famous general and my
sister said first of all though talk to
me about killing more people the idea of
killing people in response to somebody's
death is despicable and no real mother
would want to see this happen to another
mother in terms of responsible both she
and her husband said we hold these are
the government responsible for our
daughter's death because when you
maintain such a brutal oppression and a
brutal occupation against another nation
when you take away people's land and you
destroy their homes
what do you incarcerate their fathers
and quite often their mothers when you
shoot their brothers and sisters in the
in their school in the school yards this
is what we get this is the
you pay as as a society that maintains
such a brutal oppression and occupation
against another people there's a price
to be paid and this is the price that we
pay and therefore they both felt that
they both held the Israeli government
responsible because these really
government is responsible for the
reality that exists there now someone
just said that's an anti-semitic
statement you just made somebody is
pointing the finger and say this guy's
anti-semitic what do you have to say
about that
well I'm Jewish so being anti-semitic is
nonsense yeah why number two being
anti-semitic means being racist against
Jews I'm not racist against Jews but I
am critical of the State of Israel I'm
critical of Zionism which has really
nothing to do with Jews although they
claim to so there's nothing anti-semitic
about criticizing Israel a fact most
Jews don't even live there most Jews
never accepted Zionism so I don't think
there's that has anything to do with it
it's a claim that's being thrown out
when there's nothing else to say when
the other side the pro Israeli side the
side that supports the violence in
Palestine and has nothing to say they
say anti-semitic well so they say
anti-semitic
what if someone says look you he's just
a self-hating Jew have you heard this
statement yeah well I certainly don't
hate myself
anybody else I think it's again it's one
of those things they throw at you and
then they've got no argument yeah what
else we're gonna be getting into some of
the top myths that are surrounded I have
actually I was telling you I have a
student of mine who's a good friend of
mine hopefully he'll watched his show
and we've gotten into you know this talk
a few times and usually because any this
is this is a human thing you know when
you see children who are just being
killed right and indiscriminately and
then people will make arguments like
look this this weird we're being we're
the ones being terrorized you know that
you know we have to defend ourselves
right this land we came there and now
they're trying to force us into the
ocean so what do you say when you hear
things like this well it's a complete
distortion of the history and a complete
distortion of reality the only reason
there is a Palestinian resistance is
because the Palestinians
we're thrown out of their land Palestine
was occupied and Palestinians live under
a brutal regime which is very similar to
the apartheid regime that they used to
exist in South Africa therefore there is
resistance if there was if that didn't
exist if there was no occupation of
Palestine if Israel did not violently
kill and oppress Palestinians there
would be no Palestinian resistance so
you can't blame the victim for resisting
you have to look at what started the
conflict you have to look at the
oppressor you have to look at the
stronger power and the responsibility
lies in their hand I just had a rabbi
give me an analogy he said look imagine
you left your home and then someone came
and occupied it and then you try to get
it back and then they went to the judge
have you heard some of these analogies
maybe you can you could yeah that's
assuming that you know that's that's
that's taking it into a place which I
don't usually go that's making the
assumption that today's Jews are really
the descendants of the ancient Hebrews
that used to live in that part of the
world some 3,000 years ago that's a
that's a--that's a bit of a stretch for
me and even if it was true I don't think
it I agree with him it doesn't justify
you know I did not live there 3,000
years ago my grandparents emigrated from
from from Ukraine their parents their
grandparents didn't live there and I
don't know any Jew that can trace his or
her ancestors back to the ancient
Hebrews so that's a lot of you know
that's a lot of a lot of myth there and
I don't think it's relevant the point is
the Zionist movement was a colonialist
movement it was brutally oppressive and
that is that is why we have a problem
and that is why there's no peace in
Palestine we're gonna continue that's
one of the myths that the land was
uninhabited there was no people there
yeah so there's no people there it's not
being used why can't we use it so this
is one of the myths that we're gonna be
clearing up here on the Deen show with
the general son me go kill it don't go
anywhere this is really quite bizarre
because all it takes is a little bit of
reading of history to find out the disk
just isn't true
there is no congenital historic
enmity between the Arabs and the Jews
the mainstream Israeli Jewish society
believe because that's the way they had
been educated that Palestine was empty
anything empty when the Jewish settlers
came there is it really true that Israel
was a land without a people for a people
without a land Palestine was not empty
it was a land populated by Arabs who had
a high level of culture high level of
education with farms and markets and
towns and villages and roads and
Commerce and lots of interaction with
the rest of the world the populations
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly Arab
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with the generals son
grandfather was one of the original
signers of the Declaration of
Independence and 25 years blackbell
karate
yeah all right so we got some awesome
comment there okay so they say people
will say that okay look nobody was
living there
it was just barren land nobody's there
it's uninhabited what what is it true or
not well if nobody was living there then
then how is it that close to a million
people were forced out in 1948 those
people came from the moon or something
there were people living there and they
were forced out in in what Israel calls
the war of independence I think more
more accurately is called the campaign
of ethnic cleansing and terrorism that
forced Palestinians out of their homes
and out of their land and into refugee
camps mostly and which is why today we
have a four million Palestinians living
in in in horrific conditions in refugee
camps both in Palestine sometimes
minutes away from their land and in
other countries around around Palestine
all you have to do I mean look at
pictures listen to stories I mean the
Palestinians were there they were always
referred to as a people and to say that
there are no people there is just
complete ignorance are you saying that
also the textbooks many people they
grow up as kids reading you know the
history books are the history books
tainted absolutely there's a book that
came out my sister Anna Reed is a
professor at the Hebrew University she's
an educator and she published a book
about two years ago called Palestine in
Israeli schoolbooks and the question she
asked was how is it that Israeli
children who grew up in what seems to be
a liberal democratic society and when
they're 18 they put on a uniform and
they become monsters and they suddenly
are capable of terrible atrocities
against the Palestinians so she decided
to take a look at the Israeli schoolbook
so these early textbooks and she took
some time off and she did some serious
research into the schools that are being
taught in Israeli high schools and she
found clearly that the Israeli education
system is tainted and racist racist
completely racist and it follows the
models of other racist colonialist
societies give us an example
well the way Palestinians are portrayed
in the textbooks are there either
portrayed as non-existent as some kind
of a problem like poverty or as
terrorists there's not a single
portrayal of a Palestinian as a human
being the maps the way the maps are
portrayed in Israeli geography in the
geography books it's always a map of the
entire country with no recognition of
Palestinian cities or towns or
population Palestinians are like a
nonentity there are Jews and there are
others and the others are not really
marked so Israeli children growing up
what all they know about Palestinians is
that they're either some kind of a
environmental problem poor and filthy or
terrorists this is the only frame of
reference that they have even though
it's a very small country and and
everywhere Israelis live is no more than
a 10-minute Drive from a Palestinian
community but that's the other problem
which is that it's a very segregated the
country Israel segregated it in a very
effective way so Israelis never meet
Palestinians you know I grew up in
Jerusalem I was born and raised in
Jerusalem and most of my life it was
completely occupied it was supposedly a
mixed City I never met a Palestinian
until I moved to the United States I
never sat and talked to Palestinians
until
in the United States I was never with a
Palestinian where the laws that applied
to my life and the laws applied to their
life was that were the same laws until I
moved to the United States because back
in Palestine Israel
that reality does not exist and so this
is how Israelis are raised to view
Palestinians and at the age of eighteen
they're given a gun and say these
enemies they're trying to kill us
we're trying to push us into the ocean
and there's no mention at all of what
the Zionists did in 1948 how they
committed these terrible crimes against
the Palestinians apartheid we know this
was an evil thing in South Africa and
many people can relate to the back of
the bus now in this country when they
say look you got to get to the back of
the bus are we seeing the same thing
apartheid kind of get to the back of the
bus happening in this neck of the woods
it's apartheid for sure it's not so much
get to the back of the bus type of
apartheid it's more legal and so there's
there's real segregation in the
communities so we rarely take the same
buses but the laws that govern the lives
of Palestinians are completely different
than the laws that govern the lives of
someone like me in Israeli Jew for an
Israeli Jew like myself I come and go as
I please it's a liberal democracy I can
speak my mind I can you know I mean it's
I can I can I can I can sell my house I
can buy a house I can get a job I mean
it's a completely free society of free
country for me Palestinians live in one
of three different legal categories they
either live under a brutal military
regime in parts of the country or they
live as alien residents particularly in
Jerusalem and if they're away for a
certain amount of time or if they end up
moving and having a citizenship in
another country then that is because
that is revoked from them they have no
right to return and then you have the
Palestinians who live and they actually
have some kind of an Israeli citizenship
and they're live under a set of laws
civil laws that discriminate against
them specifically and this was set up as
soon as the State of Israel was
established this this set of a this
apartheid regime which is really when
you have different laws for different
people
apartheid regime was set up immediately
as soon as the State of Israel was
established separating Jews from
non-jews so that is definitely an
apartheid regime and it's definitely a
racist regime and it's definitely an
unjustifiable and excusable injustice so
you didn't say there is get to the back
of the bus but a totally different bus
it's a totally four bus it's in other
words the reality is different so it's
not to get back in the bus but it's it's
it's it's it's much deeper and it's a
much more complex legal legal reality
that exists there open-air prison prison
we've heard that this is the biggest
hope what does that mean well you take a
place like the Gaza Strip which is about
I don't know 140 square kilometers or
something you know it's very small place
with almost two million people living
there they've been under siege for years
nobody can come ago nobody can trade
nobody they can't they can they can go
out to fish because the guys is on the
coast only about three kilometers out or
three to five kilometers out depending
on the mood of the army you've got
almost too many people living in an
open-air prison when you people can't
come or go when people cannot do
Commerce when there are no means of
trade no means of life you've got the
Israeli army bombing them on a regular
basis they cannot build after things are
being destroyed there they can't they
have no airport they can't fly out they
can't take a boat out they can't drive
out I can't walk out that's an open-air
prison but what if someone says look
because if we don't do that then they're
gonna kill us then they're gonna end up
you know getting weapons and they're
gonna come attack us what do you say
that I said it's nonsense
if there's absolutely no proof just to
substantiate that claim whatsoever is
that why they do it though no they do it
because they want to keep they want to
keep Palestinians segregated from Israel
and they have nothing else to do they
don't know what to do with the
Palestinians in Gaza Israel created a
massive problem and it doesn't know how
to deal with it the only way it knows
how to deal with it is with violence
we're gonna take a break and come back
with more of the general Sun here on the
D show don't go anywhere
but what was created in practice was
institutional discrimination against
non-jews in other words Israel ended up
being built on a blueprint of exclusion
the Israeli government wants maximum
land and resources for Jews but not the
Palestinians living there
that's why inside Israel Jews get
special privileges including rights to
London housing that are denied to the
Palestinian citizens who make up 20% of
Israel's population in the West Bank
Israeli Jewish settlers and Palestinians
live on the same land but must live
under two completely separate and
unequal systems of Israeli law the
Jewish settlers dominate the natural
resources including water and
agricultural land and they're backed by
the Israeli army to maintain the
occupation Israel has demolished
thousands of Palestinian homes and
orchards confiscated Palestinian land
farmed a captive civilian population in
Gaza and punished resistance with raids
arrests and assassinations all to gain
maximum land while making life so
difficult for Palestinians that they
will either leave or be too afraid to
resist please subscribe to the Biggio
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show with the grandson
of the original signers of the
Declaration of Independence for Israel
your grandfather was you were born in
Israel
your father was General in an Israeli
army you know the facts not the fiction
I compared that you know we hear a lot
of different you know growing up fairy
tales and myths and this is a great myth
you know one of them we cleared out that
the land was inhabited and nobody was
there you cleared that up and and the
what's on the ground now we also hear
many things like the media and many of
politicians they'll say that look that
the Palestinians if they did have an
upper
and they would do a holocaust like the
Nazis did what would you say that well
we don't know what would happen if but
we do know what actually took place and
what actually took place is the opposite
what actually took took place is a
massive campaign of ethnic cleansing and
a slow slow genocide by the Israeli
forces of the Palestinians there's been
a constant attempt to destroy the
Palestinian people to kick them out of
our land and and kill them in a whole
variety of different ways the latest
assault that we saw at Gaza this last
summer during Ramadan Israel murdered in
cold blood over 2,000 people on prime
time with weapons that are bought that
are sold by from America or by America
to Israel money that is given to Israel
from America in other words our taxpayer
dollars we're all part of this we're all
complicit in a way unless we stand up
against it and this ridiculous claim
that there's somehow some kind of a
threat to Israel security from Gaza
well Gaza is mostly refugees the Gaza
Strip was established by Israel in the
early 1950s as a place to house the
thousands and thousands of refugees who
were thrown out of their homes and
became refugees as a result of the
establishment of the State of Israel and
now there's a problem now we've got this
this area called the Gaza Strip very
crowded and nobody knows what to do the
right thing to do would be to allow the
refugees to return to to compensate them
to pay restitution and to allow them to
return to their homes as they should as
was done in other places in history I
mean not in Palestine but Israel doesn't
know what to do they Israelis look at
Gaza and they see the results of this
original crime of the establishment of
the Zionist State of the State of Israel
now the only other solution that exists
if ur if they're not going to solve the
problem is to attack and then blame the
Palestinians so that's what they do we
know there's been never been an army in
Gaza there's never been a tank in Gaza
there's never been a war plane or
warship in Gaza there's never been a
military threat from Gaza there have
been attempt at armed resistance so we
see the Qassam rockets which have harmed
hardly no one we see we used to see from
time to time smaller groups
guerrilla fighters trying to sabotage or
cause them some damage but they've never
been able to really pose a threat yet
they are bombarded and attacked on a
regular basis so what Israel is very
good at and Israel allies is really uh
israel's allies are very good at is
distorting the story is attacking the
victim and then blaming the victim for
starting the violence which of course
isn't complete nonsense it's like
somebody I mean it's been compared to
someone just being raped and accepting
expecting that person not to you know
and then blaming the person and for
fighting back yeah yes talk to us about
the children you mentioned 2,000
innocent civilians were killed yeah more
than 2,000 and and many of them majority
were children is that right managed a
majority but many were children many
many were children talk to us about the
different the water situation the food
and the living well in an agreement
those that that was sealed by Israel the
US and Egypt's that Gaza Strip has been
under a severe siege so there's already
a severe shortage in water fit for
drinking nutrition and medicine this is
besides the attack this is was on a
regular basis on top of that on a
regular basis Israel's been attacking
Gaza for years now for decades actually
well and we see now for example there
have been heavy rains and so the place
is flooded so the UN is calling it a
disaster area once again and you wonder
why isn't Israel fixing this Israel has
a lot of money Gaza is right there
Israel has all the facilities the
medical facilities engineering
capability it's a modern state and it's
allowing this catastrophe to continue
now you talk about children we cry for
the children and all the civilians that
were that were murdered by Israel but
think of the ones who have not been
killed things of things think of the
ones that have been orphaned the ones
that are in that are in there have been
injured severely and have no family they
have no access to the perfectly modern
medical facilities that exists in Israel
sometimes minutes away not even a flight
away minutes by car away but they have
no access to these so they are now in in
orphaned quite often injured severely
injured physically and psychologically
and nobody cares there's
they're just left alone they're just
left to be you know and this is a crime
on top of a crime the few children that
are allowed are permitted somehow to go
into Israeli hospitals somebody has to
pay for Israel charges them in order to
take care of them it's this absurd
reality that it's almost hard to believe
it is so horrific but there we have it
and like I said it was done in primetime
everybody saw this Americans are paying
for this not only in money but also in
arms America supports this and keeps you
know repeating this mantra that somehow
Palestinians are Israel has a right to
defend itself against the Palestinians
the Palestinians have never posed a
threat and this is this is a horrifying
reality that has to be has you know has
to be stopped we see a lot of the
bulldozing of homes did you know a
Rachel Corrie she was also a peace
activist she was killed right yeah
protesting can you tell us so what's
going on over it was a 25,000 homes have
been demolished why is this going on
well Israel Israel has been demolishing
Palestinian homes you know for decades
this is nothing new demolishing
Palestinian homes either North's take
the land or in order to allow the army
freedom of movement especially in the
Gaza Strip or where there's such or the
population density is so high the
Israeli army goes there all the time and
and and and and does operations and so
forth and so it's much easier if you
don't have homes to go in and operate in
to what you need to do for the tanks and
so forth Rachel Corrie stood in front of
bulldozers that were trying to destroy a
home and she was just run over this is
going back for quite a few years now of
course I know her parents and then and
and their great activist and
spokespeople for the Palestinian cause
but but there's nothing new about this
in other words all these different
issues that we are talking about today
are part of a greater problem none of
these issues can be resolved on its own
unless the entire thing is resolved and
that's why it's so important to undo the
myths and to connect everything back to
what happened in 1948 when the State of
Israel was established and recognized
that
all of Palestine is occupied and is now
called Israel the entire State of Israel
is occupied land all these Raley cities
and towns that were built are illegal
settlements and there has to be a
movement similar to the movement that
existed in South Africa to replace this
very brutal racist colonialist regime
called the State of Israel with a
democracy where Israelis who are now you
know part of the part part of the
reality there and Palestinians can live
together as equals in peace yeah so I
know this was a short segment there's a
lot more to cover just one last myth now
many would say that there was always
this friction between Jews and
Christians but do we see before this
yeah I'm sorry Jews and Muslims were
they living in peace with each other
before thus this all this came about
well the experience of Jews and Arab
countries and Muslim countries was very
different from the experience that Jews
had in Christian the Christian world
increasingly the world Jews were
persecuted and the Nazi Holocaust was
what was a part of that but it certainly
wasn't the beginning and it was and you
know this was something that was part of
almost European tradition was - was was
a Jewish persecution this did not exist
in the Muslim world whenever Jews were
had to flee from Christian countries
they came and were welcomed in Arab
countries in Muslim countries and the
Middle East was a place of Tolerance
religious tolerance mostly only since
the establishment of the State of Israel
did this myth come up and this friction
come up between Jews and Muslims but
it's something that is that was forced
upon both Jews and Muslims by Israel and
by Zionist ideology and we see this here
in the u.s. today - their only reason
there's this llama phobia which is a
real issue here in America it's
something that exists this fear and this
demonizing of Muslims and Arabs is
because of the support for Israel and
the fact that America has bought into
the Zionist narrative
how can people if they want to get a
hold of you if they like to invite you
out to speak more on this
get your book watch your presentations
how can they get well everything's on me
everything's on the internet the book is
called a general son journey of an
Israeli and Palestine it's available on
Amazon or if they can go to the general
son calm or mikko pelit calm and send me
a message I thinking write me an email
Niko pellet at gmail.com I'm always
available always happy to speak and and
discuss this issue I really appreciate
you taking the time to be with us here
on the Dean show I know it was a short
amount of time but hopefully people can
get in contact with you get your book
and invite you to speak either at a
church or mosque wherever you're hoping
to go any anywhere and people should
come to this conference here the ANP
conference here in Chicago this weekend
thank you so much yeah please thank you
thank you and thank you for tuning in to
the Dean show that was the general Sun
giving you the facts not fiction and I
know it's a very sensitive topic for
many people but there is no
anti-semitism going on here just
education and we want the best for all
of mankind so from here you can go ahead
and investigate this further look into
it subscribe to the Dean show come back
here every week we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]